this is a set of headliner Hong Kong's
most popular satirical news program
people say it has a lot in common with
the Daily Show in the US people are
looking to their leaders for reassurance
and answers unfortunately we have him if
the Daily Show's Trevor Noah
the show's hosts an taeho pokes fun at
politicians knocked up by that oh my
gosh come on Lord Godalming young
certainly I got y'all you know [ __ ]
future correspondents on both shows
feature in sardonic music videos and
both shows have been intensely covering
harsh police tactics in their respective
regions of the world but recently
there's been one drastic difference then
he showed they were criticized or the
attack on the tongue very directly if we
do it just like at any show we will get
tons of the complaint letter an episode
mocking police for hoarding personal
protective equipment
amid the pandemic got the show suspended
champagne our program always make
trouble I don't think we will come back
because the government want our program
to disappear there is no more violence
the show suspension is the latest
example of how Hong Kong under pressure
from the Chinese government has been
chipping away at the territory's free
speech and now Beijing has proposed a
national security law as a way to quell
anti-government protests that tore
through the city last year the passage
of the law could affect not only a cast
of comedians but the future of the
global city the freedom of speech in
Hong Kong is not in dangerous but I
think it's already bad that's true
episode so I treasure every minute or
every second sank ji ho and his partner
youichi some often dress up as a Chinese
general and an empress she represents
the leadership in Hong Kong she always
shows she's stupid
yeah the show has always taken a sharp
look at the news since its creation in
1989 covering Chinese Pro
democracy activists during the Tiananmen
Square protests something TV channels in
the mainland didn't dare cover Sakuya
yeah man Missy Tendo Brampton again what
is that song she got headliners main
appeal since the start is that it's been
a show for the Hong Kong people and that
was never more true than when the UK
handed over the city to China like in 97
that is a very crucial moment for Hong
Kong our program we are not standing
with the UK government or the Chinese
government we stand with Hong Kong
people we try to express our worry about
our future
this past year has been a busy news
cycle with battles between
anti-government protesters and police
that rocked the city followed by the
corona virus pandemic song says the show
had to become sharper than ever before
and the episode that got the show
suspended a policeman jumps out of a
garbage can the sketch goes on to
criticize the Hong Kong police for
having more protective gear than other
frontline agencies and medical workers
fighting the coronavirus hey William you
all I need more the may Malaga after the
episode the broadcast regulator gave the
public television network that airs
headliner a warning for denigrating and
insulting the police then the government
ordered the network to conduct a full
review of its editorial process and
apologized
soon after the network issued an apology
and said it would suspend the show Hong
Kong people we are powerless we always
think that we can change our political
system what we can only do is we want to
try to make fun we want to express our
our feeling
the show suspension isn't the only
example of how Hong Kong's free speech
is being eroded the same month China
announced it would pass a new national
security law in patience Yugi Yan is a
lawyer and professor who studies
internet censorship in China and this is
the resolution Beijing approved in May
so that is the major Lee says the
proposed legislation lays out threats to
national security as separatism from
China terrorism aiding foreign
interference and subversion it's
actually very very ambiguous so it's
very possible that the court my
interpret the law widely to include a
lot of behavior which used to be
protected by the freedom of speech now
with the low people don't want to be put
in prison free speech has long been a
pillar of the one country two systems'
model based on Beijing's pledge to allow
Hong Kong to keep its own laws while
still being a part of China but that
system has been under threat the first
signs emerged in 2015 when booksellers
critical of Beijing were detained the
last year a bill was proposed that would
have allowed people in Hong Kong to be
actually dieded to China for trial
this brought protesters out onto the
streets Lee says the proposed national
security law could further jeopardize
one country two systems' many
multinational corporations major news
organizations as well as think tanks and
NGOs that value free speech and see Hong
Kong as a gateway to China are based
here and Lee says this has helped the
city become a global business up these
headliners they are pretty influential
so it's possible that they might be held
liable under the law we are very free
society so for the time being people
have this freedom to say whatever they
want to say meanwhile the leader of Hong
Kong says that the law will actually
allow the territory to remain a free
society and that national security is a
top priority given how what she calls
riots have boiled the city with the show
suspended song decided to trade in his
costume for a helmet a gas mask in a
press card they're demanding Hong Kong
independent because one just push that
push standard that's this way he's
trying in the adventure documenting Hong
Kong's issues as a YouTube vlogger
[Laughter]
for song creating a news show from
scratch isn't the same as having the
financial backing of a big network even
so he says he will continue in the
spirit of headliner
using his shows to make the voice of
Hong Kong as heard and that will test
the government's promise that Hong Kong
will remain a free society history tell
us that in China
everything everything if the government
they don't like you to say they don't
like you to do they can Kanda you all
against a national security law
[Music]